my agenda every morning every hour every
evening is to know what everybody else
is interested in not to consume what I'm
interested in so every morning I look at
the top 100 apps on the App Store every
morning when I see something is 99 and
then 87 and then 55 I'm like what's
Clapper oh Clapper is a tick tock clone
just in case Tick Tock gets banned in
the U.S understood then I look at every
trending topic then I do Google Trends I
stay curious I'm also doing things I'm a
human being my work life besides
operating I'm trying to understand why
lizzo is getting popular the data's out
there the top songs on Spotify the most
followed people the fastest Trends on
who's getting followed it's out there
when you actually put time and effort to
try to understand everything you stumble
on a couple of things along the way